Transcription: Samira Kwache
Relecteur: Anne-Sophie Matichard
Bonjour tout le monde.
Je vais commencer par une histoire.
C’est l’histoire d’un bananier.
Alors, vous avez entendu,
je travaille dans les plantes.
C’est l’histoire d’un bananier
qui poussait
dans la cour de la maison d’une amie qui
est dans la salle, et elle se reconnait.
C’est un bananier banal.
Il était là et il jouait son rôle.
Un jour où elle nettoyait sa cour,
elle a déplacé un pot.
Alors c'est pas cette image,
mais c'est pour illustrer.
Elle a déplacé un pot
comme celui que nous voyons là.
Et elle l’a mis au pied du bananier.
Mais ce qu’elle ne savait pas,
c’est que là où elle a déposé le pot,
il y avait une jeune pousse
de bananier qui commençait à croître.
Voilà ce jeune plant qui se retrouve
sous ce pot qui, pour lui,
est un obstacle quasiment insurmontable.
C’est une histoire que j’ai vécue,
et je peux attester de sa véracité.
Quand ce jeune plant
se retrouve là, en dessous,
il avait le choix :
soit de dépérir,
soit d’essayer de s’en sortir.
Il va choisir une façon très singulière
de pousser.
Alors qu’un plant de bananier
pousse en hauteur,
lui va commencer à pousser en épaisseur.
Au lieu de grandir vers le haut,
il va s’épaissir.
Il va devenir de plus en plus robuste
et au bout de plusieurs mois sous le pot,
il va devenir une masse très dure
qui va réussir à soulever
un petit coin du pot,
laissant apparaître
deux petites feuilles.
Et c’est le jour où mon amie a vu
ces deux petites feuilles
qu’elle m’a appelé
et qu’elle m’a raconté cette histoire.
Voyant les deux petites feuilles,
elle a soulevé le pot.
Et quelle fut sa surprise de voir...
...une masse !
C’était un bananier,
mais un bananier absolument bizarre.
Mais malgré tout, il était vivant
et il avait réussi
à survivre ce grand obstacle
qui était, en fait, un obstacle,
qui devait l’emmener à l’échec total.
J'aime cette histoire.
Ça fait trois ans qu’on me l’a racontée,
mais j’aime bien me rappeler
cette histoire,
car elle illustre très bien la capacité
que l’on a à surmonter des obstacles
qui, au demeurant,
sont insurmontables.
Cette histoire illustre la capacité
qu’on a de continuer à se développer
dans des conditions
absolument défavorables.
Cette histoire illustre
la notion de résilience.
Et c’est de ça que je veux parler ce soir.
Cet après midi.
Nous sommes dans une ère
très particulière.
Depuis deux ans, le monde entier
ploie sous la pandémie.
C’est très compliqué,
on ne sait pas où on va.
Et depuis plusieurs années, on nous parle
du réchauffement climatique.
Un des intervenant en a parlé
tout à l’heure.
Les conséquences
de ce réchauffement climatique sont
un impact sur la capacité de survie
des espèces, et même des humains.
Face à tout cela,
la nature et l’homme sont appelés
à faire acte,
à faire preuve d’une adaptation
très intelligente et très rapide
face à tous ces changements.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la résilience.
Je suis Docteure Virginie Mfegue,
comme on vous l’a dit tout à l’heure.
On vous a donné des titres très pompeux,
mais je veux répéter.
Mais avant de les répéter,
je veux dire que je suis camerounaise.
Et comme vous tous,
j’attends la finale de la CAN,
Cameroun - Côte d’Ivoire,
(Applaudissements)
avec un score de 2 - 1
en faveur du Cameroun.
(Hourras)
Alors, comme je disais,
j’ai un titre assez long,
un peu pompeux, comme les Camerounais.
Docteur en pathologie végétale
et épidémiologie moléculaire.
J’aime répéter ça
parce que c’est une longue histoire.
À 44 ans, j’ai eu mon doctorat.
Ce jour-là, je me souviens,
quand le jury a eu fini de délibérer,
ils sont venus -
c’était dans une école doctorale
en France -
ils sont venus et ils m’ont dit
cette phrase assez bizarre :
« Dans cette école doctorale,
on avait décidé
de ne plus donner de mention.
Mais à cause de l’excellence du travail
que madame Mfegue vient de nous présenter,
nous avons, à l’unanimité, décidé
de lui donner la mention très honorable
et on ne s’est pas arrêté là,
on a ajouté les félicitations du jury. »
(Applaudissements)
J’en parle avec beaucoup d’émotions,
mais vous comprendrez pourquoi.
C’est une très longue histoire.
Mais nous allons d’abord revenir
à notre bananier.
Comme je le disais,
comme tous les bananiers,
n’eut été le pot qui était posé sur lui,
ce bananier aurait eu
une trajectoire banale.
Il allait grandir, il allait fleurir.
Il allait porter un régime qui allait
nourrir la famille de mon amie.
On allait le couper
parce que c’est ça,
la trajectoire d’un bananier.
Mais les choses ne se sont pas
passées comme ça.
L'histoire de ce bananier
ressemble à ma vie.
Plus jeune, je réussissais
sans aucun effort.
Enfant, mon père m’avait raconté
cette jolie histoire,
où un vieil homme lui a dit :
« Il faut épouser cette femme,
elle est enceinte d’une fille dont
l’étoile va briller sur cette terre. »
C’était moi.
Et je nais dans cette ambiance,
avec la certitude
que je dois briller sur cette terre.
Et j’avoue que je brillais.
(Rires)
Je réussissais sans effort.
Alors, est-ce à cause de la parole
de ce monsieur ?
Je n’en sais rien, mais je brillais.
À 17 ans, j’arrive en Europe
avec une bourse d’excellence,
une bourse réservée aux meilleurs élèves
pour faire des études universitaires.
Et mes premières années,
comme je dis, je brillais.
Je pouvais aller danser le samedi,
dormir toute la journée le dimanche,
aller composer le lundi
et avoir une note d’exception.
Donc, pour moi, réussir, c’était banal.
Et puis un jour, patatras.
Je ne peux pas dire quand ça a commencé.
Je ne sais pas dire comment ça a commencé,
mais ce que je sais, c’est qu’un jour,
j’ai connu un échec palpable
dans tous les domaines.
Échec académique,
échec social,
échec affectif.
Je me suis retrouvée fragilisée,
désargentée,
totalement à la ramasse en Europe.
La brillante jeune fille,
qui était arrivée dix ans plus tôt,
est rentrée au Cameroun,
sans diplôme.
Et à 27 ans, je suis retournée
à l’université,
là où j’avais laissé mes études.
Le pot était sur ma vie.
Toute honte bue,
j’ai repris mon courage et j’ai essayé.
J’ai essayé à tel point
que je suis arrivée jusqu’au bout,
jusqu’à la soutenance
du diplôme d’ingénieur.
Mais patatras, mes notes
se sont volatilisées dans les ordinateurs.
On fouille, on fouille,
on ne retrouve pas les notes.
Puis, quelque chose se passe,
mes notes surgissent d’un bureau,
on ne sait pas comment.
Mais patatras, la nuit,
on vole l’ordinateur avec mon mémoire.
C'est l'histoire du pot sur le bananier.
Je ne savais pas ce qui m’arrivait.
Les choses qui m’arrivaient étaient
inexplicables, inexpliquées,
en tout cas, bizarres.
Voilà l’histoire d’un bananier
qui se retrouve coincé.
C’était ma vie.
Je me suis posée des questions,
je me suis demandée
par quel bout prendre ma vie.
Ce que je sais, c’est que j’étais perdue
et je sais que j’avais honte.
Pourquoi j’avais honte ?
J’avais honte parce que
j’étais l’espoir de ma famille.
Je suis l’aînée d’une fratrie
très chaleureuse.
Et j’étais leur modèle, leur exemple.
Quand je reviens et que je me retrouve
dans cette situation,
c’est une honte pour ma famille.
C’est une honte pour ma nation,
parce que les bourses d’excellence,
on nous les donnait pour aller nous former
et revenir travailler
pour faire avancer le pays.
Et j’avais honte pour moi-même.
Je me disais,
j’ai les capacités de réussir.
Donc si je ne réussis pas,
c’est qu’il y a quelque chose
que je ne fais pas bien.
De toute façon, le plus simple
aurait été d’abandonner.
Mais je me suis dit,
je veux bien me poser des questions,
mais le plus important,
c’est de trouver des réponses.
Je veux bien identifier mes problèmes,
mais si je n’ai pas la solution,
je ne vais pas m’arrêter.
Il y a un facteur clé dans ma vie,
je suis croyante.
Et je pense que nous n’avons pas été
créés au hasard.
Je crois que chacun d’entre nous
a un but particulier sur la Terre.
Je pense que nous sommes
dans une espèce de bateau collectif
et que chacun a un rôle à jouer.
L’échec d’une personne,
c’est l’échec d’une collectivité.
Je crois qu’à ce titre,
nous n’avons pas le droit d’échouer.
Je veux parler de la résilience.
Nous rencontrerons toujours
des obstacles sur notre chemin.
Le plus important,
ce n’est pas de se lamenter,
mais c’est de chercher à s’en sortir.
Pour moi la résilience, c’est quoi ?
C’est la capacité
à contourner des obstacles.
La capacité à trouver des plans B,
parce qu’il y en a toujours,
de chercher une issue de secours,
même quand toutes les portes se ferment.
Pour moi, c'est ça la résilience.
Je vous parlais d'un bananier.
Il n’a pas cherché à comprendre
« Qui a mis le pot ?
Qu’est-ce-qui se passe ? »
Lui, ce qu’il cherchait,
c’était survivre.
La résilience,
c’est de chercher à survivre.
C'est l'instinct de survie.
C’est de se dire qu’on ne quitte pas
la Terre sans avoir écrit son histoire.
Et c’est ça qui m’a portée.
Je me rappelais des rêves et des espoirs
qu’on avait mis sur moi
et je me disais :
« Je n’ai pas le droit de laisser la vie
m’empêcher d’atteindre ces rêves. »
Et c’est ça qui me portait.
J’ai tiré de nombreux enseignements
de ce qui m’arrivait.
Pour moi, la résilience s’inscrit
dans cette devise de la ville de Paris.
J’aime cette devise que j’ai découverte
il y a quelques années
lors des attentats que vous connaissez.
[Fluctuat nec mergitur]
Je ne sais pas si c’est comme ça
qu’on dit.
C’est une expression latine.
Ça veut tout simplement dire :
« Tu peux être battu par les flots,
mais tu ne vas pas sombrer. »
Nous sommes comme des roseaux,
nous pouvons plier,
mais nous devons toujours nous redresser.
Ça, c’est une de mes philosophies de vie.
J’ai tiré de nombreux enseignements,
j’en ai tiré trois en particulier.
Le premier, c’est de ne jamais,
de ne jamais abandonner,
de ne jamais cesser de se battre.
Je ne vous ai pas tout raconté,
mais j’ai vraiment eu
des choses très particulières.
Quand on cesse de se battre,
c’est qu’on a laissé
la vie avoir le dessus sur nous.
J’aime bien ce poème,
d’un certain William Henley.
Ce poème a été repris par Nelson Mandela,
qui a dit que c’est grâce à ce poème
qu’il est resté un homme debout
pendant qu’il était en prison.
Ce poème, William Henley l’a écrit
alors qu’à 16 ans,
on venait de lui couper une jambe.
Et il le termine par ces deux phrases :
« Je suis le maître de mon destin.
Je suis le capitaine de mon âme. »
Un jour, je me suis dit,
personne ne viendra relever
les obstacles à ma place.
Personne ne viendra changer
la situation à ma place.
Si je suis le capitaine de ma vie, alors
je dois prendre mes responsabilités.
La résilience,
c’est de ne jamais baisser les bras.
Deuxième enseignement que j’ai retenu,
c’est de toujours regarder devant.
Fixer ses objectifs.
C’est une chose est de tomber,
mais s’en est une autre de se relever.
Mais tant que tu fixes les yeux
sur tes objectifs, tu vas avancer.
Je me souviens, un jour
où j’avais fait un champ de tomates
et je longeais la piste d’un aéroport.
J’entendais les moteurs
de l’avion en train de -
les réacteurs qui se mettaient en place.
Et je m’étais dit ce jour-là,
j’ai tellement sillonné le monde
et aujourd’hui, je suis appelée
à passer à travers un aéroport.
Je suis maintenant du côté cour,
mais un jour,
je reviendrai du côté jardin.
Fixer ses objectifs.
Plus tard, c’est bien ce qui va arriver.
Je vais faire mon champ de tomates,
dans le petit village,
puis, je vais être recrutée
comme chercheur,
et pendant 4 ans, je n’ai pas de salaire,
vous imaginez ?
Je faisais tous les petits travaux
dans le laboratoire.
Tout ce qu'il y avait à faire, je faisais.
Un jour, alors qu’une équipe
d’américains et de français était là,
ils ont demandé :
« Qui fait ce travail ? »
On a dit : « C’est elle. »
« Elle doit aller se former,
aux États-Unis, en France,
et qu’elle fasse une thèse. »
C’est comme ça que j’aurais ma thèse.
La résilience, c'est d'accepter de faire
des choses auxquelles on n'est pas appelé
pour pouvoir s'en sortir,
c'est de contourner.
Si je pouvais pas aller tout droit,
j'allais contourner.
(Applaudissements)
Pour moi, il n’y a pas sous-métier.
C'est ça, la résilience.
Plusieurs restent sur place
parce qu’ils ne veulent pas contourner.
Il y a deux choses que j’ai retenues.
Ne jamais baisser les bras.
Fixer ses objectifs.
Il y a une troisième chose,
c’est de ne pas abandonner ses rêves.
Imaginez,
quand je me retrouve ce jour-là,
à repartir aux États-Unis,
dans un avion dont le bruit des réacteurs
est en train de faire [bruits de moteur],
je me rappelle quand
je traversais l’aéroport
pour aller planter des tomates
dans un village.
Et je me dis, case cochée.
C’est bon. Obstacle, tu es évacué.
(Applaudissements)
Ma vie, c’est un ensemble
de cases que je coche.
Et pour moi, c'est ça la résilience.
S’il y a eu un obstacle,
il faut continuer à se battre,
jusqu’à dégager l’obstacle
et toutes les conséquences
de l’obstacle dans ta vie.
Ma thèse, c’était une conséquence.
L’échec scolaire était
une conséquence des obstacles.
Ma thèse a été une façon d’évacuer.
Reprendre le travail,
c’était évacuer des obstacles.
C’était enlever le pot au-dessus de moi.
Je veux parler à quelqu'un
de cette façon d'être.
Je pense que pour moi,
la résilience
c’est de pouvoir refuser la fatalité.
C’est de dire, il n’y a pas de fatalité.
La seule fatalité,
c’est de cesser de se battre.
Pour moi, la résilience,
c’est dire oui à d’autres possibles.
Et même à l'impossible.
La croyante que je suis,
sait qu’un jour, le Seigneur a dit
à Ézéchiel :
« Est-ce-qu’à partir
de ces ossements desséchés
des personnes, une armée peut revivre ? »
Et il a dit oui.
La résilience pour moi,
c’est avoir cette faculté de dire oui,
même quand ça semble impossible.
Pour moi, la résilience, c’est
ce que les croyants appellent la foi.
Mes proches me définissent
comme quelqu’un de très fort,
de très tenace,
et je salue mes frères et sœurs
pour la confiance et cette amitié
qu’ils m’ont toujours données,
même dans les moments difficiles.
J’embrasse aussi mes fils,
qui sont un grand soutien pour moi.
On me définit comme forte,
tenace, persévérante
et jamais je ne baisse les bras.
Mais, c’est plus compliqué que ça.
C'est un ensemble de beaucoup de choses.
Nous sommes le résultat
de nos échecs et de nos réussites.
de nos blessures et de nos succès.
Je suis le résultat de tout ce que
j’ai fait et qui n’a pas marché,
et de ce que j’ai fait et qui a marché.
Je pense, pour ma part, qu’un arbre
qui a été battu par la tempête
est plus solide qu’un arbre
qui n’a pas de problème.
Je me crois forte à cause
de tout ce que j’ai vécu.
(Applaudissements)
Et c’est forte de cette expérience
que j’arrive à dire aux personnes
qui sont perturbées,
dont la vie est gâchée,
qui se disent :
« C’est fini pour moi » -
je passe pour celle
qui encourage toujours les gens,
parce que la résilience,
c’est ça aussi.
Quand on a des problèmes, on a tendance
à se replier sur soi-même,
à en vouloir à tout le monde.
Mais pour ma part, être résilient,
au contraire, c’est s’ouvrir aux autres.
Je suis sûre que ce bananier,
pendant qu’il grandissait sous ce pot,
permettait à des insectes, à des fourmis
de pouvoir aussi profiter de sa présence.
Quand on a des obstacles,
il faut devenir très généreux.
Pour moi, la résilience rime
avec la bienveillance.
(Applaudissements)
Je veux conclure sur ça
et je veux dire à quelqu’un, quelque part,
qui entendra ce Talk,
si ça peut l’inspirer,
je veux juste lui dire,
il n’y a pas de fatalité.
À chaque situation,
il faut pouvoir trouver une solution.
Je veux pouvoir dire à quelqu’un,
quelque soit la situation,
il y a toujours devant nous
une nouvelle ère qui peut s’ouvrir.
Alors, comme je le dis toujours aux gens,
Never, never, never give up !
N’abandonne jamais !
(Applaudissements)